thank you
thanks for coming on the show yes i'm
very excited to be here
so pumped um
thank you for inviting me
thanks for accepting and
playing so nicely the last couple of
hours and even the last time we hung out
it's just been
great vibing together and
yeah on unconditional freedom
it is yes
yeah always already free always your
song comes up
yeah
i love that one yeah always already god
yeah
unconditionally free
[Music]
singularity
that's actually the first thing that
that that came up when i was seeing your
instagram
i just saw the the the singing videos at
first and i was like oh this is so cool
yeah this is so authentic yeah yeah this
is so playful i really
you know by now that i really enjoy
playfulness yes and not all that
seriousness all the time yeah although i
talk about serious topics but
in a very playful way
yeah yeah
yeah
and you've also had an interesting
awakening where you
which we'll talk about actually this
could be a great first topic is that
and then also how
there was a shift where you began
creating content on instagram on youtube
and felt so playful and so basically
generous just sharing about what
happened and then just this
all of your other selves then turning
towards the content that you've been
generating and being like wow this is
actually impacting my life beneficially
and then
um
so yeah so let's let's dive into that i
think that's a great that's a great
first topic um
so tell us about like what has
transpired
uh for you in the last
just say like specifically like the last
year has been like the most
transformative yes that's the most
intense transformative year ever
[Music]
yeah it's been an epic year because
actually
one year ago
i didn't even know about non-reality
i only came to know about non-duality in
2021
in january
yeah
but there was a lot of seeking prior but
it was just seeking in other directions
because i didn't know about nonsenity
so the seeking energy was already fired
up so when i came to know about
non-duality it was like oh my god i've
been looking for this but i didn't know
that it was this
yeah
yeah
so that was act i think in january 2021
i read about free will in a book that
there is no free will and there was
simple examples of that that we cannot
predict our thoughts and that will come
in the next 10 seconds for instance
and that kind of
made an energetic shift in me i just at
the moment i thought that was just a
great insight
but
days passed i lost some kind of
resistance and then i was like was it
about this
quote that i read or
what is it and then i got back into the
writer and
and it's a dutch writer that talks about
non-reality he's not really famous
he does like zoom sessions and then i
got on those zoom sessions and from his
few videos on youtube i came to know
about my advaita teacher
who is
um
talking about advice of redundant
non-duality in a very sober
playful and funny way
but also very confronting and i would
say he's a master in what he does and
how he interacts with seekers
he lives also in holland it's a dutch
advisor teacher
and from that point on i was just
obsessed
it's the only thing
that really mattered to me it was
finding
who am i
yeah
as prior to that there was seeking in
religion for years and
and trying to attain peace um
but it was so different totally yeah and
and then uh prior that like fina
reading a cartale trying to be present
conscious
it was all about getting a better
experience but as i entered this field
of non-duality as i can say
it was a destruction
a beginning of destroying all that i
knew yeah
or all that i thought to be true
in a very fundamental way
yeah
that was insane
yeah so it was an insane year
yeah
interesting so you could
say that there's a
a build up
of
not only conditioning and separation and
lack beliefs but there's also a buildup
of
seeking
principles to make experience better yes
yeah
okay and then then there's the
deconstruction of all of that exactly
because then in non-duality i only found
out that
hey
there is a transcendence possible of all
experience
which i didn't know
prior that that i was possible i was
looking for
indescribable peace inexperience which
can never be found
um
yeah
so the seeking energy become very became
very intense i was watching those
satsang every evening
almost
on youtube i lost interest in in in my
social life and everything was was
happening
also corona i forgot about corona like
all these things were going on in
holland and his restrictions i didn't
care i was on youtube watching
the
satsang yes yes yes yes and actually i
also connected with the teacher i
did some sessions via skype
um and which actually were a catalyst
for the spiritual awakening that
happened i think a half year prior to
realization
um i i would say that was like the
second
stage of the spiritual awakening because
i think three or four months prior
finding out about non-jealousy i had a
kundalini awakening which is quite
intense
so that's actually what i would say the
first part of spiritual awakening since
you shift
energetically
to
you have an energetic shift which is
very
um opening
the whole conditioned body
and the condition mechanism started to
uh sh yeah she be shaken up by this
force of love
the shakti the life force
um yeah
and that was actually triggered by a
transmission that i received from
a friend of mine which is a friend now
she gave me a transmission from this
crown chakra
and which activated my kundalini energy
and
this is not something a lot of teachers
talk about or or speakers about
non-reality they don't they kind of
dismiss it but to be honest what i found
is
when i talk to people in my sessions
who already had an awakening they
haven't
activated condolences they are less
prone to constant only conceptualize
everything they're more open it's just
another way of understanding than people
who haven't that's why i talk about the
importance of the life force energy i'm
not i'm not talking about kundalini yoga
this is something else that's a practice
of will
and kundalini activation transmission
that i received is a transmission and a
relaxation that actually does itself
so that's the difference and i only had
i think
three session three transmissions and
the
life force energy awakened that does not
happen for everyone because she has a
lot of groups that that she gives these
transmissions
i think
the
people that are
not in this avoidance
of emotions and and really opening up
and open-minded it happens easier that's
what i observed
from my own observations
so it's not that oh let me get a
transmission and i'll get a spiritual
awakening that's not how it is
um
there's more to it but there has been a
very
um
a very strong catalyst
yeah
for for the opening up
so when i read about the fact that there
is no free will
i
did not only conceptualize it and put it
into a box of knowing
it did something to my energetic body
some part of resistance fell away
and that's how i felt like what what is
going on
so this vehicle the body-mind vehicle
was already opening up
yeah
yeah
so
there's two things that i'd like to
cover
um
two threads
one of them i think is important to
to share which is
the you give a
like a macro level perspective which is
that there is only god's will or there
is only the singularity's will so
there's not an individuated yeah
expressions yeah
um
we are all being done
yeah exactly yeah it's all being done
yeah
and then
um when the
individual at first is seeking let's say
that
there is a
there are patterns of the way that
they're expressing themselves
and it seems very frozen we could say in
like an analogy it feels like the way
that they express themselves is very
frozen because it's
it's the repeating of the same patterns
over and over again
um patterns of separation or lack or
unfairness fear this type of thing
then
there's a recognition um of some type of
you could say like um
desire to
uh know why they suffer or something
like that yeah that was indeed the
reason why i started seeking
why do that why don't do i don't have a
peace of mind
yes that was the first question
and this is probably the most common one
is that
okay how do i be happy or how do i be
peaceful um and then so that's probably
most common and then it gets deeper into
knowing my true nature yeah um and in
that process is you could say the
unfreezing of those repetitive patterns
so it shifts from repeating patterns
unconsciously to you could say gaining
more sovereignty will or insight into
nature
and then the process of like the
surrender of will
happens when you're
merging more and more with what is um
so there's almost like an
there's almost like an increase in will
over a period of time and then a
surrender of will to god's will
in in the big picture none
but also simultaneously the appearance
of there being an unfreezing and then a
surrendering
i just wanted to clarify that that that
seemed to be important did that resonate
and then there's another thread that we
can get to
yes that's a a different explanation
that i would use but i sense what you
mean
yeah
as for me i was
i was
from this
um
contracted
personality looking for freedom
and then that that couldn't be found
because there was this misconception
that i am a separate doer
with free will and choice to make this
or that happen and that creates a lot of
suffering because that's just a
misconception
from this contracted
personality
so when i got clear on that
misconception
that opened a portal
to
realizing
what is freedom itself
and still get to enjoy
this appearance
of a person
nice yeah yep
because i'm never avoiding it
or trying to deny it yeah
the the the appearance in this um
um
separate person
from the view
like the separate body
which is not separate at all but it
appears to be right we're not glued into
each other
um
so
yeah
this combination of what you talk from a
bigger perspective from a smaller
perspective collapse into one as seen as
they were never
separate to collapse but as a play of
words one could say that
nice and then another way to
to speak about it is something like
when you find yourself sort of trapped
in those patterns that that is the
unconditional freedom expressing itself
as being trapped in patterns
[Music]
the unconditional freedom expressing
itself as the appearance of gathering
its will and then liberating itself from
subconscious patterns of separation and
lack
and then surrendering its will to the
unconditional freedom that it already
always was
it's just another way to to share it
so it's always the unconditional freedom
appearing as a spectrum of infinity
infinite possibility
[Music]
okay so then this other thread that i
wanted to pull on with you was that
also in this last year you've spoken
about how
there was uh
falling away of the veil of separation
take us on to that yes yes
so after having this spiritual awakening
i felt really expanded
and really blissful and i thought that
was it
but i didn't say i'm realized that
didn't happen but i felt like there is
something
uh some kind of a conclusion but i
couldn't really grasp what it was but i
think that was the
leaving the personal identity but i
couldn't find the words for it because
it was so intense what actually happened
but i felt
very expanded very blissful a lot of
seekers
who have a spiritual awakening
might think it's a realization because
it definitely feels more free
than
being in sep being in this contracted
energy of a personal identity so i felt
like i moved shifted from being a person
to consciousness that's how i felt back
then
and
what actually happened then is a a a few
months of a blissful expansion i started
to write a lot and and about the
awakening
uh write poetry and just dance in nature
and and i i don't know just enjoy
the the wonder of being alive but there
was still seeking
so there was still the seeking energy i
kept listening to satsangs but with a
very
in a very happy state
so that took i think around two or three
months and then i think
it started to dawn on me that there's
really no separate
doer or like there's really no free will
or choice
in any of what's being done so
and that kind of simultaneously
triggered
darkness like a dark dark night
of i wouldn't say so i would say will
the dark knight of the will i kind of
slide it into that
as it started with frustration
i ended up most days
for i think two or three months
in severe anxiety and dread which was
not attached to anything external
it was just existential
so i would wake up at that point i
wasn't really into stories anymore so i
would really dismiss all the stories
that i made mind came up with but my
body went into a fight or flight
response
because
yeah of course i can
make up an explanation for it i think it
was just it started to down on me that
there is no
me as i thought it was
and it was really energetic so i would
wake up with anxiety
and then
shift to dread
and then just stare out of the window
and thinking everything is so
meaningless because i cannot make
anything happen but i still do think
there is a me in here that makes things
happen
um
and i ca yeah and that's where i came
across
uh the
communication of jim newman and tony
parsons
so you can already sense how that
that was even more direct and more
uncompromising that than my advice
teacher
that i had my awakening with by watching
his youtube videos
so then
i found myself becoming obsessed with
watching those videos every evening
and basically lost all interest in
worldly things in my social life
work-wise i lost all my ambitions goals
while i was an entrepreneur and i had a
lot of ambitions but i basically lost
everything that i wanted
uh i didn't know what i wanted to
achieve i basically didn't want anything
because it was so depressing
just to realize there is no me that's in
charge of what's happening here i cannot
even
decide what thought i will have or
desire will rise up in the next 10
minutes i don't know
um
yeah
and what i did
at that period i remember i
stopped avoiding emotions that actually
happened already for a year
that i just fell into whatever arise i
was really cautious of really
spotting all my
avoiding strategies getting into the
stories of what's happening avoiding
this raw sensations
of being confronted with this direct
message but also in my private life
being rejected
by a close family member
and someone that i liked
so there was a lot of emotional things
going on as well which were really a
catalyst of a
kind of breaking down the protection
mechanism the walls
which one could refer to as the ego
which is really has a function to keep
you safe
and from feeling
fear pain
rejection uh
grief sadness all those things that we
were conditioned that are not safe to
feel that we were unable to process it
so i was kind of rewiring that
conditioning of
feeling and then immediately uh avoiding
it so i was really in the dark night i
would really um
whenever the anxiety attacks would arise
i would really feel into those
and um
basically just lay on my bed for a half
an hour
and just do nothing
and just ask myself how does it feel
to be
so anxious and to be
to have so much dread
i talk
a bit extended about this because a lot
of seekers that are contacting me
have these experiences you see it's not
about the place and like that can happen
as well in this
journey of awakening but a lot of people
that watch the uncompromising message
they go like oh my god everything is
crumbling and it's terrifying
because it seemed that there is nothing
to hold on yeah
that was the most terrifying thing there
is nothing to there is no strategy there
is no practice yeah
this is it yeah
and there is no illusion
but i feel as if i'm separate but there
is no separation so it was really
frustrating because there was also no
hope at some point there was no hope
left to get what i want realization
enlightenment
so
i became really uh
yeah depressed for a few months and i've
never had a real depression in my life
so that was new
um
i had sufferings and challenges and
divorce and things like that so it's not
that i haven't suffered but it was not
severe as that
so after that those months of feeling
through the pain and the most horrible
attacks of anxiety and just sitting with
it with not trying to hide from it was
really what what happened yes
and then i kind of at some point i was
like
i'm waiting for the dread to move but
maybe i should just stop caring about it
yeah and i kind of also get got used to
feeling like [ __ ]
after those months you know and
i basically also fell through the most
intense painful bits of the sensations
of of of of dread and anxiety that at
some point i just stopped being afraid
of
having anxiety
or being afraid of having a dreadful day
[Music]
so
then it's it moved it moved on
and i kind of
felt like i entered what frank yang
would say equanimity phase
equanimity
so i didn't care about being depressed i
didn't care
of course there was this inclination to
pleasure and feeling good
but that really
didn't matter that much anymore
so in that last month
prior realization of that field of
separations
dropped away or actually nothing really
dropped away but it felt like
something dropped away that was in front
of my eyes
in that month prior to that
i didn't really care about realization
anymore
because i was seeing if it happens there
will still be this
this moment
this
nanosecond
of what's happening apparently
so
i kind of lost hope that i will gain
something else than what was happening
so basically there was this moving on
from the fantasy of getting in line
enlightenment
there was a kind of a shift from that
like okay it's just this so yeah i'm
dreaming to have this big party
happening yes that at some moment i will
get uh realized but i don't think it
will have because you know what i was
calling jim a few times and he basically
said
um
there is no illusion to get rid of
this is it yeah
so if there's an experience of
separation that's the absolute arising
as an experience of separation that's
what longed for
so what i actually did because there was
still obviously a lot of resistance
towards the experience of separation
i kind of brainwashed myself into
thinking there is only perfection
i had it like a as a reminder in my
phone that went up every hour so i would
put it on i had it on my screen there is
only perfection
there is only what's apparently
happening so it's thoughts arise
conversation in my head arise emotions
arise resistance arise that's just
what's happening
so
at some point there was just no
my kind of this body-mind vehicle
uh got used to
letting go of resistance very fast as it
arose very good
and at some point it just stopped
yes
so that was actually the reconditioning
of
of trying to manipulate what's happening
because that's a very
uh that's like the crown
of the illusory separate self is always
trying to manipulate what's happening
it's it's never good enough yeah exactly
it had always
could have been different well it
couldn't because it's already happened
it's already history yeah you see
whenever something happens it's already
history
so that fell away
the dream of enlightenment fell away
as a dream as something that would
happen
and
there was basically this desert period
of
just nothing to hold on
i didn't know what tomorrow will be like
i didn't know what next day next moment
will be like
so
it was terrifying and uncomfortable but
that was what's happening
because i recognize there is no media
can make anything happen other than
what's happening by itself
i know this might sound very terrifying
for a lot of people that are listening
now
that
being in this floating
place of not knowing yeah
like not
having any sense of control although
it's like
false
security like even losing that dream of
false security
that was terrifying and that's also the
phase where a lot of people run back
to something to hold on to a method to
something to do
but actually
is the opposite it's just
not doing those things
unconditional freedom found in the
mystery exactly yeah
and at some
point there was a day where i was
dancing in my living room
and then there was this thought that
oh yeah i was sitting with this pointer
that
i got from someone
that there is still a fear to lose the
illusory separate self
what's that fear
so i was sitting with that pointer
because i didn't know what that fear was
then all of a sudden there was a fear
that arose
that said if i will lose
the
separate
the me
i will lose my funny crazy side
and then there was another thought that
arose but hey there is already no me
and then that view of separation which
was like
some kind of cling foil yeah i was in
front of my eyes just fell yes and i
remember i was
looked up and i saw the walls
and they were so spacious like in one
second everything became spacious
as not that i saw something else but
this was just
empty
appearance and i turned off the music
sat down on my couch
and i was looking at what the heck is
this because there were no words
no thing to nothing to associate this
with it was not an experience
it was not an experience
so i couldn't even think that this is
enlightenment that i didn't think that
at all that whole evening because there
was just no real i couldn't relate it to
anything it was nothing that i've
expected from realization at all
and then
i just spent the whole night just in my
bed afterwards
and i um i couldn't explain what
happened
at that moment i didn't think that i was
realized because i was just like what
the heck is this
it's so clear
spacious and fascinating white walls
that are so alive pure
aliveness
in this simple house that i'm living in
i've never seen it
how fascinating the appearance already
is
and nothing changed it's not that i see
something else than i saw before it's
just
it's not an experience there is no
experiencer that is experiencing the
walls or the house or sitting or
anything so everything became very
immediate
i remember the day after
i looked in i think the first moment
that i looked in the mirror
i saw
a body in the mirror not a reflection of
myself
yeah it's as if you see a friend
standing in the mirror next to you you
see the body in the mirror right you
don't see a reflection of you from his
body so that's how i saw myself also
called the headless way i think so yeah
i think so
and then i was like oh my god i think
i've lost the center because
the seeing i don't know where the scene
is coming from
i couldn't locate the seeing
and that's when i thought
i think this is realization
because before that the day before that
i just couldn't
relate it to any
word
like transcending spirit you cannot as
an experiencer you cannot imagine how it
is to transcend experience it's just
impossible you can't get it like an idea
but it's nothing like the real thing
because it's not a
thing
so then
i started freefalling
so the feel of separation stopped
happening and then i started free
falling into unknowing
which is also like the same as
transcending the mind so i felt insane
and my mind felt like it was going
insane
and i felt like a child
like a baby
and then i was like playing in my heart
i was like oh my god i don't i i also
thought like is this alignment this is
so weird because i don't feel
enlightened i feel like
crazy like something in between an
insane person and a baby yes
[Music]
and i didn't feel special at all that
was the funny thing i thought as a
seeker i thought this enlightenment is
an add-on you see that i add onto myself
and i'll feel more special more wordy or
at least better
but i didn't feel
like a difference from a plastic cup
and myself
when i looked at other appearances
i i didn't see it like a difference
between this body and that appearance
like it's just the same which is just
different it looks different
so i didn't feel special at all it was
very humbling to be honest it's very
humbling and the funny thing was that
i realized there is no need to become
enlightened there is only enlightenment
there's only wholeness exactly which is
already in life exactly exactly and that
forgetting of it also
an inevitable phase forgetting that
you're also it
yeah so then there were a few crazy
weeks but not in a weird way that i
would like nobody noticed anything like
it's not that i did something disturbing
but i really felt insane for a few weeks
but i was enjoying it because i felt so
like i felt like drunk on love yeah high
on life
but in a very um grounded and very yeah
immediate way so it was not as a
spiritual awakening that was like very
blissful and there was of course bliss
but it was very
um
clear also yeah and still
like there was this constant this
stillness was
i don't know how to explain it it was
constant in my ears i don't care how
much thoughts were arising there was
still this
stillness in my ears
yeah
and um from that on yeah i think after
that i started to share about this
because there was so much inspiration
and i think just this freedom to express
myself the way i the way that i felt
felt natural
so then i started to use instagram for
sharing and facebook and and created a
youtube channel and just started talking
in front of a camera
and that's what i still do and i also
hold sessions
with people
because i worked as an integrative coach
prior and now i'm also combining those
skills
uh with non-duality
yeah
you're a very good listener you haven't
interrupted me once with so much
goodness
so there's only these little windows to
like add a small bit to
like to play on and
now there will be something new and
fresh that emerges that just complements
what you just shared it's really great
it seems to be most direct to
to share that there is only wholeness
and or freedom
and it's appearing
in infinite potential
so there is the potential of it
appearing like it's forgetting itself
and then the experience of separation
yeah
so then the rocket ship you could say is
to just recognize
that
um
there's no possibility for something to
be lost um
yeah yeah and um
that
the you
that you've associated yourself with
your whole life
um
has been
like the body
um
like your brain
um
and that
you're actually
um
you're
an infinite field
yeah
and um
a field is is uh energy and energy is no
thing it's not a thing
um
and
it's also everything
and so
it's uh yeah so this is the shift in
identity
from
the appearance of forgetting to
remembering is just shifting from
being the brain in a body
and being attached to identity
personal
to just being
pure potentiality actualizing itself via
what you could say is
the appearance of universes and
conscious agents and
dancing with each other on planets
orbiting stars which is just a bunch of
story that we're saying right now
and that just feels
that feels like freedom
you know that feels like freedom
um but then it's not
just
the feeling
and
the
simultaneity of knowing and unknowing so
the simultaneity of
of uh
of being it and also being mystery is
there's no way to describe it to be and
not to be it is and it isn't yes exactly
yeah and it seems like a paradox but it
isn't because there are no two yes right
yes it's a complete mind [ __ ] most of
the people that i encounter they say i
got my mind
i got so many mind books today by
watching non-duality and hearing this
message
it's it's so interesting because um
because
yeah there's a
there's like a stuckness
to
two-ness
yeah it's like really sticky
um
like
subjectivity and objectivity
yeah and awareness
oh like a lot of people that are
actually in the last stage
prioritization get stuck with this
awareness trap
like trying to be aware
as if it's possible not to yeah like and
you know and and making
that a stumble block wow it's actually
um not needed to be that way
that was actually the last hold on that
i had trying to be aware
and then i was like okay there is no
choice in this practice doing it or not
it just happens or not
and then there was just nothing to hold
on
so this knowing our consciousness or
awareness
um
was also set free
yeah was nobody trying to get it
yeah
as if it's lost
because by trying to get it you're
confirming that it's not here yes yes
that what you're looking for is not this
what's happening is not good enough we
need to
have something else
in order to
become the freedom that already is
so that's an avoidance
mechanism
so actually a lot of awakened people
that are not realized yet and that's a
desire because not for everyone
that is a desire which is completely
fine because there is no rule to
have it or not
they're avoiding there is this avoidance
of realization by
doing
all these hold ons yes
that's why i talk about this awareness
trap also oh my i think also frankie
mentioned it in one of his vlogs
yeah
yeah that was a good video
yeah because there's a simultaneity of
of no stages
and stages and
yeah one could say that uh
the most contracted sense of identity
brain body um
is ego that's constantly
seeking uh externally
and then there's this like relaxation
into awareness
and then there's a shift into okay well
awareness is still a duality there's
awareness a subject and then there's
object and then there's a collapsing of
that duality into everything is god i am
everythingness
and then there's a realization of the
other side of the coin which is that
well
i am also a formless
nothing
and that
that
sort of obliterates any last little bit
of a contracted sense of self behind the
eyes
um
and so then you get the two sides of the
coin which is no self and capital s self
or nothing and everything
and then the more that you sort of even
relax the conceptual juggle and you
relax like wanting to be no self or
wanting to be
self and all this type of stuff then you
could say like there's a natural state
that just emerges when you transcend all
possible
concepts of trying to say what you are
yeah and you just alright but then the
key thing about you just are it
that i've seen is that
you get
expressions of that
where it is just
talked about but it's not
uh
it's not
like vibrational or it's not actually
expressed so meaning like
um if you were truly expressing that
last stage you could say that the way it
would express itself
would be in
pure service to life in a sense it
wouldn't be trying to still extract
things from life so if you claim that
you've reached some sort of natural
state of existence
and then you're
still
run by subconscious patterns of shadow
and of
doubt and unworthiness and fear and
um
seeking validation
yeah you're still trying to get the flow
towards your direction instead of just
flowing out yes yes exactly and so then
you could say that that's the
generosity versus consumption
and so basically
if you if there is a cl if there is a
claim to be at an um natural state
then the expression
is
solely generosity um
and
so then that becomes more energetic or
it becomes vibrational when you're
around people so no matter how um
no matter what people say about
themselves
um you can dig deeper than uh words into
the energy of it the vibration of it and
you can sense generosity versus
consumption
yeah it's really that needy needlessness
yeah yeah
that arises from it and that doesn't
mean that there can be desires i think
as long as there is a body there are
desires
but it's completely different it's just
what's happening
and the main flowing is outwards there's
just this flow going outwards
and that doesn't mean we
lose the human capacities
certainly not
i don't think that people will notice
anything when they're around me like i
function like a normal person um
but there is this indescribable sense of
fulfillment
which makes one transcend neediness yes
yeah
yeah and that's very liberating
very freeing
and that certainly doesn't mean that one
solely
commits to service
because there are different characters
and different expressions
and different way of service
one can commit to or not or
you see
and for males and females that's also
expressing different
because the cons the the
the
constellation of the body is just
different
so for me there is also a lot of playful
uh time for play
and dance
and creativity next to the sessions that
i offer and the content that i put out
i found out to be so
important
um
yeah
and that's a quality that i honor i've
honored the feminine essence
um because
by honoring that i make the body mind
vehicle more
like energetic wise balance
and
the being can just express itself in a
more clear and
focused way
than if i wouldn't honor
my essence
yeah
yes
as a polarity yeah
on a relative level we're still
having the limits of that
which doesn't have to feel like a limit
there's so much um to play
with
uh entanglement
where
the
there's no difference between the
absolute and relative yet there is also
an apparent
um
difference where we talk about things
like um
masculine and feminine and polarities
like yeah poles is a great way to put it
like
um
where we where we generally use concepts
to generate a difference between
physicalism and consciousness or
whatever um and in doing so
it
um
it just
yeah i guess it enables the absolute to
have a conversation about what's
appearing
yeah yeah
yeah it it really creates the fun the
polar the opposite polarities like i
also usually say it's the celebration of
unconditional love and unconditional
freedom and
expressing itself as a being
other polarity
which can be quite
a learning process and how to find this
experi
experiential
wholeness
as being expressed in polarity right yes
yes
yeah
i don't know if that sounds
for me that sounds very conceptual
but i don't know why i expressed it that
way
i guess that's what i wanted to be
expressed
to me
it seems like what is arising right now
is it's a rising
the
um
in a sense it's like the desire for the
absolute to know itself at a deeper
level for example for me the entire
point of the universe is that
um the entire point of the universe is
to
have an absolute
intelligent infinite
energy
explore
expand
[Music]
and
the way that it shows up is not limited
to anything that we
are generating by concepts in mind
so
um
yeah so yeah at some point um
like
we we said a little bit earlier that
a service doesn't have to uh show up in
any specific boxed way um and that's a
it's a great point
um yet also
it's clear in a sense the
freedom
also
is not only
omnipresent but it's also
a
one of the coolest you could say tastes
of freedom
is
to serve
and need yeah yeah so you can be free
sitting in your room by yourself yeah
where you could be free when somebody
doesn't have their basic needs met or
when they're struggling with suffering
and you serve them yeah because they're
seeking wholeness or healing so
uh yeah
yeah so that's a little contrast at
least uh indeed it's such a joy
to share
and to serve
and to it's really
the joy sometimes really overflows me
on certain moments of the day
after a conversation during a
conversation or by make creating content
it's just it then it's just seeing that
this is what's long for
to share and it's just love expressing
itself
i don't feel like i'm creating the
content or that i'm doing it or that i
don't i certainly don't speak from
knowledge since i don't have that much
spiritual knowledge i really speak from
realized wisdom
and
it really feels like unconditional love
is unconditional freedom is flowing
through this body-mind vehicle
and it has a certain taste to it because
this character is obviously different
from another character
and the language that i use and the way
i make analogies and descriptions is
different
but it's such it has been such a joy
ever since the moment that i started to
share
yeah and the brain is so efficient
using all the qualities that i have and
also i certainly have some qualities i
know i'm not that technical and stuff
but
everything figures itself out
because this is so aligned
yeah
i think this is the first time i've ever
used this word alive
yeah
yeah but in this context it was just
perfect yes
yeah another way that
aligned
can be
put into the context of
a
peak
archetype or symbol could be
said that when your
thoughts
speech and action are all aligned in an
example like
gandhi
and
the level of just
just
non-violent
uh
catalysis
for spiritual awakening
is just uh
it's just unprecedented in examples like
that and it um it's a great
north star or symbol or archetype to
is again it's a big uh
array of colors or like a palette and so
it's not to box
you know pure service as that and that's
the way it shows up
but that
um there's
yeah yeah you yeah you
um
just
being
uh
samadhi in your room by yourself is
service um so there's there's many
um
and so this is a good example is that
yeah it's also
it is also service for
um for the one to
you know this this gets into territory
that is a little bit um more
difficult to comprehend or to explain
but it's just that even the one
appearing as
suffering as um
the disaster and war and basic needs not
being met and all these things even that
still serves
infinity in its exploration and it's
indeed it's inevitable base yes yes yes
indeed
yes and what i wanted to mention about
service
yes service has two phases you were
either
serving ourselves
or we serving the other
[Music]
and
serving the other is the most fulfilling
yeah but what appears
most of a lot of service that appears in
the world at this moment now right now
is really only serving themselves
which is very understandable because as
long as there's this experience of
separation and lack
and there is no clarity on that there is
no honesty about that
because there's i'm certainly not
judging anyone who
sometimes feels that because that's a
natural natural face
as one
enters freedom
prior to that
but before this recognition this service
will always be
self-centered even if that can be like
very
high hidden
or people try to hide that
but the most fulfilling is when it's
really
for the other and you get just to get
the joy of it of doing it just
expressing
what needs to be expressed yeah
oh yeah because i have had phases in my
life where i thought i was serving i was
a first i had
my own business in stationary hour art
and later
as an integrative coach practice
i thought i was serving but a lot of my
conversations
were still
um were not 100 percent
free
totally they were still a self-image
that wanted to be protected or defended
well it was a client session they paid
me for it
and i was very honest with me about that
like i did confront myself and i learned
from it
but it was just hopeless yeah that's
what i found out like
because first i i had this shift to like
an ambition phase from to a purposeful
drift and that's where i started my
coaching press and did become a licensed
coach
but i still was like get it it's still
somewhat so unfulfilling because i'm
seeing i'm serving me
because now i feel good about myself
having this purpose and
helping these clients
well still some shadows will pop up and
really kind of disturb the the session
and of course most clients don't even
notice
um
but yeah at some point i was like oh my
god
separate self i need to get rid of it of
course that's not
not how i ended up thinking about it but
at the beginning it was like oh my god
no matter what i do as long as there is
this separate self it will ruin ruin the
whole party
yeah
yeah i also didn't take it too serious i
was very playful with myself
but yeah it was is the way it is
yeah the universe is a birthday party
being ruined by the separate song
it's a celebration of unconditional
freedom and unconditional love
that actually can be ruined but it can
seem as if it's getting ruined
just
like
and it's like the person that comes to
the party um
and then they like
talk really loudly only about themselves
to everybody else like yeah
interrupting conversations to just focus
people's attention on themselves or
whatever that can arise yeah yeah yeah
yeah that is kind of like what it feels
like like on like the macro scale like
in terms of the planet like
yeah
like one big expression of
the one that feels
um unworthy and then seeks
its other selves to validate itself
yeah
yeah
and then the liberation from that um
is then the always already free or
wholeness yeah which can then be
uh
leveraged as a channel
exactly usually
when that transformation happens
is when people
tr
they still have this quality wanting to
talk about them some people are just
talkers
and there's nothing wrong with it but
then that quality is used in a way to
serve people so then they use their
story or their example to
um
to benefit other people so they still
get get to have the talk if they are
talkers but now it's a catalyst for for
ex
yeah freedom
or
purpose or whatever that might be for
for for different
characters
um
but it's just like
i see a lot of qualities that people
have that are not necessarily bad but
it's just by this belief of lack
they are
not
expressed in their purposeful way
you see yes
yeah like we just talked about this
on uh yesterday's show on radical
self-acceptance where
we
mentioned the
the difference between when an artist
is
still coming from a place that is
intertwined with unworthiness and
seeking
yeah versus when they're just this yeah
yeah exactly exactly such a cool
difference yeah it is it is and you see
there is also this uh spiritual
misconception that after realization one
has to behave a very humble way or not
even talk about themselves like that's
[ __ ]
you can still
talk as much as you want but it's not
coming from a place of lack for instance
i benefit exactly exactly i benefited so
much from the videos from frank yang and
he
totally talked a lot about uh
his experiences and afterwards asian as
well but it really was benefiting so
much
and um it's even worse it's
um
selfish to not share exactly yeah it can
be like that yeah but you know after
after realized freedom there the
selfishness wouldn't be right
can't rise anymore
um there can be a priority of well-being
of oneself which
there's nothing wrong with that
but what i what you mean yeah
that that yeah all these other selves
that are seeking
yeah and you're on some mountain top
yeah
i'm too good to share
well i don't think that that that will
arise but there are a lot of
people yeah that's a reason for sure
there are people that just say there is
nothing to do and they don't feel
motivation
to to to do it but you know what who am
i to force them to do anything or to say
that they should share
like i have literally a friend
that just had a realization i think two
months ago
and she just doesn't get anything done
she says like it just doesn't happen i
don't know what to do
and it's just i don't feel it like doing
anything and just taking a shower and
eating some things and just having a
walk that's it so who am i to say that
she shouldn't do anything
but it will arise
when it will arise like i don't think
that we can
stay in this non-doing for too long like
that gets boring so the body-mind
vehicle will find itself
a purposeful activity that they will
enjoy doing
yeah every moment
yeah
yeah
yeah because even non-doing is an
activity exactly yeah i tried so often
to stop seeking
as a seeker
and i remember my advice the teacher
would go like yeah there's no you two to
decide to stop seeking like they're just
seeking energy and that will exhaust
itself
and i was so frustrated why can't i just
stop seeking then the whole seeking will
be over
yeah
yeah and then afterwards i let go of
that as well
but you know in this community of
non-duality that i encounter on
instagram
a lot of
people
are in this
phase of
dark knight slash frustration with
seeking
and i really don't know what to do with
themselves
just lately in the last month i
encountered a lot of conversations with
people who are finding themselves in
this desert period that's why i also
promised them that i will make a video
on this dark night and what i did what
did not do what helped what didn't
and really trying to
elaborate more on that to connect with
them on that on that
phase
because it's really an emotional roller
coaster
pre-awakening after awakening
um
that i'm surely not denying that it is
not easy
yeah waking up from the dream of
separation yeah
waking up from the dream of
having a contracted sense of identity
that you were manipulating everything
arising to try and extract and consume
things for that contracted sense of
identity
and so waking up from that is um
yeah um very intense and destroying but
it's liberating and yes and it's truth
and it's freedom and it's
bliss and it's activation of service and
all this type of stuff and so
the entanglement is so present there and
so to just decipher between
um
like
dark knight and
honor
pure service
like just decipher
so
yeah
yeah reach out if someone who's watching
this video and is really in this desert
place or dark night or whatever
reach out you don't have to sit there
alone
trying to figure it out just
reach out
yeah one of the biggest things that is
evolving is
spiritual communities but the key thing
there is
um
there's
a good amount of spiritual community
that is
still in what you could say is more of a
uh
yeah and there's there's
major variations of spiritual
communities and so
but like nargis is sharing right now
there's um spiritual community that is
um
resonant for you and so to sort of tune
into like okay well
um
going and following her on instagram or
following her on youtube and then
reaching out for a one-on-one and just
seeing what happens like was that
actually resonant
who else does she follow um who else
does she talk to
um yeah i don't really talk too much
about spirituality
most of what i talk about is non-duality
but
i'm sure there are people that will
resonate with the way i talk the way i
speak
i also
yeah
offer people
a clear understanding in their emotional
uh how emotions
get in the way of seeing things clearly
and how we
can
have clarity on what not to do
on when emotions get really intense or
are being avoided
that really makes it more easier
to understand what's really going on
and then liberation from that
yeah
yep yeah
and then there's other tastes of
what you could say spiritual community
or non-dual community or however you
want to call it
where
there's more focus on purification
there's more focus on just seeing
patterns of consciousness and becoming
more interested in when you come from a
place of unworthiness or lack or
separation or whatnot
versus when you come from a place of
honor and pure service and so there's
and these are things like the no limit
society which is what we're
building here um
and there's so many other examples of of
spiritual community across the planet
and so just to tune in to
maybe
what
is going on for you right now is that
there's a a persistence on mainstream
society like there's a hook if you
as we could say where
there's a pattern of expression that's
addicted to what society has taught you
and it's been programmed in like malware
and so now it's running the show which
is i have to work in a career that's in
mainstream society um
i have to
uh earn money to pay for my rent and my
bills i have to
um
i have to eat a certain way i have to
consume certain media i have to
be a part of certain economies and
certain nations and um go to these
certain things with my family
and
that is all a bunch of
just thoughts it's just mind activity
and the difference is to see that
there is more
than just all of that malware
and what is more than that malware is
pure unconditional freedom itself which
is freedom from all those thoughts
freedom from all of
that mind chatter
and
usually it's enhanced by
surrounding yourself with other people
that are rooted in the unconditional
freedom itself so there's no better way
to
perpetually be unconditionally free
which is what you already are
than to get involved with
other selves that are
that
and that are only that
and don't subscribe to the malware which
is
everything that was we were programmed
with i actually never watched the news
so when there's something extreme
happens
i hear it from my mom
or i don't i don't know
yeah i didn't knew that there was a new
restriction that we we had to wear the
mask in the shops recently here in
holland
i didn't know i just people said to me
in the store and it was fine
so that's actually
something that's limiting the the
the the malware
in my life
yeah it just doesn't happen anymore it's
just nothing interesting out there
yeah there are a few
um
more modern
channels that are things like basically
telegram groups yeah yeah yeah that have
a greater focus on um the nature of
reality and
um and build building shambhala
basically um and shifting away from
the polarized media and the
uh governments and economies that are
centralized uh oligarchical
um
yeah it's a great shift that's happening
also on financial like in uh
yeah yeah
yeah that's like a very
main fundament
from this decentralization like because
money is really important to
it's it's equals safety for most people
so that shift was a major one
yeah
yeah
yeah that shift is
13
years old um
and it only really became popular you
could say within the last like five
years and yeah um
yeah with without a doubt that's a
that's a core pillar of where we're
heading um
and you see this is another thing
you can't throw the baby out with the
bathwater which is continuously done by
i see it continuously being done in
nonduality
um which is that
uh
what we call manifestation
um
uh has
no feedback loop into experience which
it does
it does a centralized government and
economy has a different feedback loop
into your experience than a
decentralized government and economy
one of them being focused on the whole
and being focused on the actualization
of collective potential and another one
being focused on a select few yeah
true and that's just going to have a
different feedback loop into experience
and so the more that
the more that
consciousness
wakes up to
its nature the more that
the expression or the manifestation
actually
serves the whole
and so that's a critical thing so
everything you do with shadow work
everything you do with deconditioning
yourself from separation it feeds back
into the manifestation being more
oriented towards the whole yeah
sure
shadow work is a major one
i see a lot of
especially male
seekers who are kind of skipping that
because that's the daily work that
people don't want to do
including me
well i've didn't sense a lot of walls
hanging out with you
so yeah but in the last year though that
was uh okay a good uh for me in the last
year it's a good catch to
uh
in a sense be like there's no walls and
then
yeah and then
and then realize that
that's actually compensation for the
fact that there still have been some
roots to dive into to liberate oneself
from which in the last four months
especially being here yeah hanging
around with other people yeah i have
already seen those patterns of shadow
yeah and consciousness then there's a
greater amount of ah i see where i was
coming from and where
there was actually a greater amount of
freedom and a greater amount of dropping
walls that was actually enabled and so
it feels yeah it feels so much better
100 though on on men especially yeah
yeah
yeah it's really important like what i
see a lot of people that ask questions
especially on instagram or like i have
conversations with
there is this in non-duality there is
this
bypassing
mechanism going on that people want
realization or enlightenment to get rid
of the suffering
while the suffering is actually the key
when it's really truly felt true
and embraced as far as that's possible
so then in limey becomes an avoidance
strategy of what is
well enlightenment is a concept
realization is a concept there is only
what's apparently happening and if
that's pain and there is like this
avoidance of pain and running away will
that will
go on endlessly running away from
shadows running away from pain so that's
not something that works
uh
in the path to liberation or this
so-called path to enlightenment
um
we're opening up everything that's not
free
here bit by bit
so the last
shackle or how to say it in english
will be
stumbled away
and and that can happen in a moment of
grace
or
just
in a moment of destroyment
and yeah
there has to be this willingness to open
up
so you can't just want freedom but
still holding back
it's not free exactly yeah so i really
uh encourage people to do the dirty work
yes
um
because that's what's being avoided in
non-duality community non-duality world
um
nice yeah nice i'm glad that you also
really clearly see that yeah because
it's it is because it's funny when when
when uh people come to me and ask what
to do what not to do and then they want
an advice but when i hit the most uh
painful spot there is this response of
yeah but there isn't anybody that can do
anything right and then i go oh we have
a great bypassing here going on
all of a sudden there isn't anyone to do
but first she came here for advice so
who's that one then trying to get advice
and now
denying that there isn't me like yeah
then there is that that's used as a
bypass like advice bypassing yeah so
that doesn't work with me i can just see
through that immediately and because
i've trained myself to to as a seeker to
see that i didn't accept
i think one like me people ask me what
how come that was so fast the
realization has happened relatively fast
i think i was just confronting myself
with every
bit of avoidance
in that last phase prior realization
of course the direct pointing of the
speakers
that was just amazing that that happened
compromising on duality messages as to
start off with it and then the
uncompromising message to finish off all
the hope that was left
for a false sense of security in the
future
to be realized
[Music]
but surely this confronting the
willingness to confront
and his eagerness
to do the dirty work as well
i think i assume that played a big role
in this liberation
um and i encourage people
to look
inwards
in that same confrontational way
because i'm not special at all
not more intelligent than most people
didn't have that much luck i wouldn't
say with all these things
it's really
the willingness to confront
and not hide not avoid
and yeah
there that's where freedom lies yeah
yeah beautiful there's
there's a self-inquiry component and the
self-inquiry component is not solely
the
intellectual recognition of non-duality
yeah it's that's a part of it part of it
yeah there's the liberation from all the
roots of conditioning that have been
running the show
um
and
i'm really happy that like doing the
work is something that you also sure
because yeah when nonduality goes
directly to there is no you to do shadow
work
it's great
really good actually it's really good to
mention to mention that
just check in like uh
like um
like when you when you dedicate your
life so much to service that
you recognize that doing the cleanup and
going on the offense with doing the
cleanup so like getting really excited
about doing
yeah leads you to pure service yeah
which is what the whole game of the
absolute is even about
um
that's what the game is so you may as
well
uh turn in
clean up all the conditioning separation
lack beliefs unworthiness seeking
validation
and then purify where you're coming from
in your expression so that when you do
serve it's not it's never coming from a
place that's other than emptiness that's
always just coming from um from that and
it's not picking up any of those little
bits of separation while it's on its way
out it's like so good because then
it's if the feedback loop becomes
it's like the most delicious meal that
you can
it's not expressing it can't be
expressed in words that joyful
fulfillment right
yeah that is and you know the the
opportunity to do shadow work is
actually rising every day every day
there can be a trigger especially
as we're still seeking uh every day
there is a trigger
so
how is that dealt with is that of being
avoided
or is that really fell through the
sensation of that contracted
energy that we call emotion energy in
motion that wants liberation that's why
it's triggered yes exactly it wants to
uh free itself but usually well what
happens is when in the intent most
intense moment of that there is this
resistance comes in
and and it's just left there yes it's
just left because resistance is
inevitable
at the beginning but at some point
it has to be seen that it's not working
it's keeping itself in
hostage
yeah
so there isn't surely there isn't
someone that can choose and
to do it but there is a brain that can
pick up on the wisdom that is shared by
us by other people
and
by having that in in in this
storage of information
making other choices in the future that
happens apparently but it happens
so that's why
this information is shared because we
are
functioning organism
that is from the brain is functioning
and making choices and and
weighing options based on the
information that it has and doesn't have
so that does influence even though there
is no separate medius a lot of people in
non-duality love to talk about when
a painful moment arises yeah but there
is no me or oh you know what what people
also sometimes say is that
there is a painful emotion they go like
yeah but nothing is real
anyway so why feel that emotion
it's not real yeah what happened
it's so good i got rejected but it's not
real right
[Laughter]
same person goes
to have a conversation with someone else
like an hour later
and in that conversation you'll clearly
see them
coming from a place that's like trying
to get validation from that other person
because they actually haven't done the
work
so if they would
do the work which is going into their
heart and their gut and the conditioning
then
feeding the pain feeling the pain
then
what was just intellectual about
non-duality actually becomes visceral
which shows up as pure service so in
that conversation they would have an
hour later they wouldn't be trying to
extract any validation yeah at all it'll
be a lot less yeah yeah yeah yeah so it
shows up in the way you express it it
shows up of course
there is no hiding we can try to hide
but there's no escape
sooner or later it will rise
backfire
yes
some sexy ass
notes over there
hi everyone
we love you so much oh do we have
comments we're
we're streaming this yeah yeah there's
some people watching social comments 27
people right now
love you guys
so cute one of the best channels there
is
[Laughter]
high five
[Laughter]
good job guys yeah there's so many other
great
like
nargis having her youtube channel i
highly recommend you guys to
to tune in
thanks guys you're so cute
joanna
jason
oh
michael
source healing
thank you my friends
so sweet
so much gratitude itself
it's really been expressed
yeah
so
so in the links in the bio you'll find
norgis's youtube channel
you'll find her instagram awesome pages
to go and follow great content on there
and
soon we'll have the link to her website
uh later this month which will be
unconditional hyphenfreedom.com
still working on it
and that link will be in the bio once
it's available
um that will be the main portal where
people can book sessions exactly yeah
so
um
right now it's just via email instagram
and yeah yeah dms on instagram and then
at this moment it is cool
um so book a session also if you'd like
only if it resonates if it resonates
yes um
so with this video
um
if the conversation on unconditional
freedom
triggered something powerful in you we
would love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below so leave a comment with
how it influenced you
and also um if it influenced you
positively like the video because that
helps the algorithm subscribe to the
channel if you haven't yet and also
share the video
with others that you know it would
positively influence so this is a great
opportunity to take a great
conversation on unconditional freedom
and share with people that you feel like
are beginning to like tune into this and
then just have them
watch it and then
get into a conversation with them about
what came up for them during it i would
also be curious if people can share
their most valuable insight from this
conversation i'm just curious that's
awesome
yeah in the comments yeah
yeah your most valuable insight from the
conversation yeah that's great
drinking the last drop of water
nice
yeah i feel like yeah i feel like we
are going to wrap it up how was the time
now oh yeah yeah great exactly 90 like
we planned
90 minutes and
yeah
and we covered all the awesome topics we
wanted to talk about
um
love you a lot
love you too thank you so cool
lovely to do this to have this
conversation yeah this wonderful space
yeah in the lines yeah
yeah supporting
yeah and just what a beautiful beautiful
energy you are
thank you
so good
thank you mirror
so courageous seriously really
courageous
yeah stepping up and sharing like you're
doing right now and yeah it's so much
easier without the self-critic yeah
which i used to have my whole life
would prevent me from sharing my my my
skills and and just expressing myself
and now that's just not happening
anymore
i still make mistakes i still say
something's wrong maybe some words
english is not my native language but
it's you know what i don't care
it's just so joyous
yeah yeah
thank you yeah
with
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so
cute yeah that was really a surprise
yeah you surprised me with that fact
that you could speak russian
that was cool
yeah and do you speak dutch too yeah and
english which is really cool yeah yeah
recently i started speak english yeah so
cool recently and still so fluent which
is great
it's cool yeah yeah i think it is thank
you so cool it's been a bless hanging
out here such a blessing and now we're
gonna have dinner yeah i'm gonna make a
walk exactly yeah exactly a walk on the
town baby
so pumped
cool um in the beginning of a beautiful
friendship also so many more cool
creations to come between us
so stay tuned all right fam love you so
much
infinite love thank you for tuning in
thank you
bye
you